[Musik]
hallo und herzlich willkommen zum bild
buschfunk heute mit einer großen
premiere ich habe zwar keine
dschungelkönigin an meiner seite dafür
aber eine waschechte prinzessin zehn
jahr von sachsen wir werden gleich noch
darüber sprechen über diesen mann der
für so viel furore gesorgt hat im camp
und zwar eric stevens ich bin sehr
gespannt was deine meinung zu diesem
jahr sehr fragwürdigen herren ist aber
vorher wollen wir sie liebe zuschauer
noch einmal up to date ping und ihn
einmal sagen wer von diesen ganzen
schlangen eigentlich noch im camp ist
elf kandidaten waren es am anfang
mittlerweile sind schon ein paar aus
janina joseph yam
tara tabitha
jasmin herren und gestern abend dann
tina ruland sie lag bei den umfragen
eigentlich gar nicht so weit hinten wir
haben auch ein bisschen bei bild.de
gefragt da bleibt eigentlich immer
relativ weit vorne jetzt ist sie aber
raus und tatsächlich hat unsere kollegin
kyra ortmann tina voland heute morgen
schon getroffen und mit ihr besprochen
und deswegen wollen wir jetzt als aller
erstes mal nach südafrika schalten zu
unserer junge reporterin pegah ordner
guten morgen sagt wie geht es tina du
hast sie quasi getroffen als sie gerade
mit dem jeep raus aus dem camp ist die
erste die sie quasi vor dem mikrofon
hatte was hat sie erzählt
ganz genau tina ruland war auch noch
sichtlich erschöpft es war nämlich eine
sehr kurze nacht wie hier in südafrika
sind ja eine stunde weiter als ihr mit
der zeit in deutschland seit das heißt
wir haben die entscheidung dass tina
ruland rausgeflogen ist er heute nacht
um 1 uhr erst bekommen und dann wurde
sie schon um sechs uhr aus dem camp
geholt hatte dann noch ein paar hat
pressetermine intern für rtl und hat
dann tatsächlich direkt sich mit uns
getroffen sie hat aber gesagt ihr geht
es gut sie hat ja bis zum schluss
zusätzlich wäre noch liebend gerne drin
aber jetzt ist es auch in ordnung jetzt
freut sie sich auch jetzt auch ein paar
luxuriösere tage hier im luxus camp hat
sie ihr euch dann verraten dass sie die
nächsten tage so machen wird wird dass
er so relaxen und chillen oder wie sie
sich die sendung noch mal angucken was
ist ihr plan
ja auf jeden fall denn sie hat ja
tatsächlich noch gar nichts aus der
sendung gesehen sie wissen auch gar
nicht welche themen genau veröffentlicht
wurden und so habe ich seid ihr auch auf
eric steht fest noch mal angesprochen
und auch da sagte sie sie hätte auch gar
nicht bis jetzt immer noch nicht richtig
verstanden warum er diese prüfung
abgebrochen hat sie hat dann nachher
gesagt vielleicht war es einer dieser
gründe wie sie zum beispiel selber kein
fleisch in den prüfungen essen wollen
würde und dass eric daneben da auch
seine prinzipien hätte dass er wirklich
aus prinzip diese prüfung abgebrochen
hat das hatte sie bisher gar nicht so
auf dem schirm und deswegen wird sie
sich heute erst noch mal die prüfung bzw
die ganzen sendungen angucken dann
wahrscheinlich auch erst noch mal ein
paar wein trinken mit ihrer
begleitperson im hotel und abends
schauen sich dann die begleitperson und
auch die ausgeschiedenen kandidaten also
jasmin herrin und karabiner dann die
gesunden die sendungen zusammenhang
ihrer vielen dank für deine schilderung
von vor ort lässt uns wie immer über
alles auf dem laufenden vielen dank
ich sehen ist kann es schon mal
angesprochen ewig steht fast immer noch
das thema im dschungel den kandidaten
war gar nicht so richtig bewusst was da
eigentlich passiert ist und weil es
bestimmt auch einigen zuschauern nicht
so ganz bewusst ist wollen wir uns jetzt
einmal noch diesen großen knall von eric
steffers der vorgestern tatsächlich eine
prüfung verweigert hat um die kandidaten
zu bestrafen doch das wollen uns noch
mal angucken
möchte dir zu dieser dschungelprüfung
antreten
ich bin ein star holt mich hier raus
haben die prüfung nicht gemacht
aus dem grund weil es hier menschen gibt
die zum einen ganz offen sagen dass sie
mich scheiße finden
und zum anderen dass es hier menschen
gibt die meine gefühle ausgenutzt haben
indem sie mir irgendwelche fake
geschichten erzählen ich weiß auch noch
nicht ganz genau ob ich mich weiterhin
bereit erkläre mich an die regeln zu
halten weil ich es auch nicht möchte
dass diese menschen ihre
luxusgegenstände behalten warum auch und
ich bin auch nicht bereit für alle hier
waren es waren platz zu schaffen die
irgendwelche scheiße erzählen hier eine
sache noch beheizt wird und falls ich
hier bleibe rate ich euch wenn ihr essen
wollte mich nicht in die prüfung zu
schicken weil sonst geht so weiter
ja gestern dann große läuterung und auf
einmal war eric gar nicht mehr der täter
sondern irgendwie das opfer
[Musik]
ich wollte ganz kurz nur euch sagen
dass es mir leid tut kommt von herzen es
ist dann doch ein thema anscheinend
hochgekommen bei mir was ich vielleicht
dachte dass ich schon verarbeitet habe
oder so
hat viel mit vertrauen zu tun und
das wurde sehr sehr oft schon
erschüttert und so und
ja weil bisher seit anfang an seit wir
hier sind habe ich das gefühl steht
dieses wer spielt wer spielt nicht im
raum dieses schema klar und das sind ja
irgendwelche ängste die rum schwören und
ich hatte also ich möchte keine angst
vor euch haben oder davor hier verletzt
zu werden
ich bin ich auch das ist ein teil von
mir der heute herausgekommen ist sage
ich ganz ehrlich
wer spielt wer spielt nicht wer macht
nur schwer ist fake oder ist es
vielleicht eric der eigentlich fake ist
xenia du bist hier schon die ganze zeit
schon so ein bisschen so gut
zusammen rein ja sagen also ich das
war's die dschungelshow die letzte
kapiert dass ich das meine 18 fällen
schuldig gemacht habe das heißt ich habe
das spiel auf genug durchgespielt dass
er jetzt zum ersten mal ich kann
verstehen dass es bei ihm irgendwelche
psychose und sowas ausgelöst hat der
mann hat einen drogenvergangenheit kann
ich alles akzeptieren aber mein aller
erster gedanke war von anfang an er ist
der prototyp von meinen ex freundin also
wirklich stehe das müssen ja ich glaube
dass jeder weiß
wie polar irgendwie auch könnte auch
barkeeper sei
irgendwie bisschen hilfsbedürftig main
wegen männchen kopf streicheln aber an
sich super toxisch und das ist er ich
stehe fest für mich ich glaube dass
einfach reality nichts für ihn ist und
dass es eben auch nicht unbedingt gut
tun die entschuldigung jetzt gut
wahrheiten ein bisschen merkwürdig alles
aber glaubst du ihnen das was er da
jetzt gesagt hat nimmt ihm die
entschuldigung ab oder glaubst du dass
das vielleicht wieder hörte ich sagte
marian wird für mich wirkte das so er
hat gemerkt dass er die ganze zeit
unterm ran darf liebten und eigentlich
nicht so richtig präsenz hatte er hatte
mal gedruckt seine frau aus bisexuell
das ist irgendwie keiner eingegangen und
dann hat er sich so dass ich muss
irgendwie mal irgendwann kracher setzen
statt sonst wird das nichts mehr mit mir
ich muss stattfinden
dann hat er diesen diese explosion da
irgendwie angezettelt und dann war es
ihm aber doch relativ unangenehm und
eigentlich ist ja auch gar nicht so und
hat er sich schnell wieder entschuldigt
also für mich wirkt das alles nicht so
richtig auto das glaube ich auch nicht
also ich glaube dass der authentisch
sind im moment tatsächlich war da wo er
wirklich diesen in seinen augen
wahrscheinlich beruf gemacht hat und die
prüfung verweigert hat um die anderen zu
bestrafen hat sich das komplett im recht
gesehen was totaler blödsinn ist also so
funktioniert dass eine gemeinschaft halt
auch einfach nicht und ja irgendwie ewig
anhängen gemacht hat irgendwelche
komischen busch dünner gebastelt und ja
da noch einmal da wahrscheinlich thema
jetzt stehen wir hier leute draußen
eigentlich hätte ich doch keine kohle
und vielleicht viele leute mich dann
jetzt doch blöd wenn ich das so stehen
lassen und dann zu kreuze kriechen also
ich hätte das wahrscheinlich genau
wieviel lieb auch gemacht und hätte dann
gesagt so ja du bist jetzt okay für die
nächsten tage aber an sich weiß was sich
auf spannend fand wie er es geschafft
hat sich so vom täter er hat ja wirklich
den richter gespielt hat gesagt ihr
redet über mich erzählt mir scheiße also
spiele ich jetzt kein essen und ihr
dürft dürften hungern er hat gerichtet
und am nächsten tag hat er dann auf
einmal erzählt jahren da sind so viele
gefühle oben bekommen dinge die ich
nicht verarbeitet habe und dann hat er
auch noch mal wieder seine
drogenvergangenheit rausgeholt habe
funktionieren wahrscheinlich wir wollen
diese szene noch einmal angucken
ich war ja sehr lange drogenabhängig
zehn jahre ab crystal meth genommen bin
jetzt hier das erste mal wieder in so
einem körperlichen zustand ich bin sehr
abgemagert ich habe dieses hungergefühl
wenig schlaf und
dieser zustand hat das so ein bisschen
getriggert wieder eine diese denkweise
von früher es ging permanent darum wie
kommt man an sein zeug und andere
irgendwie auszuspielen gegeneinander lug
und betrug waren tagesgeschäft
sie sehen ja ich verstehe was er sagt
aber dessen ist man sich doch auch
vorher bewusst oder eines vor bewusst
ich war drogenabhängig ich habe die und
die probleme und sollte man sich dann
nicht auch anders damit
auseinandersetzen und dann vielleicht
lieber auf die camper zu gehen und mit
denen die probleme besprechen stadt
gleich so überzugehen ich bin sowieso
ein großer freund davon direkt von
anfang an die karten offenzulegen also
hätte zb musik ganz ja auch sehr gut
getan hätte sie das ads einfach direkt
von anfang an angesprochen hatte ich
habe adhs dass nur ein bisschen was
anderes aber ich fühle das halt dass die
menschen einen nicht verstehen können
und so was kann man nicht offen rede das
ist aber auch ein prozess und es ist gut
dass jetzt so gemacht aber ewig steht
fest hat ein buch darüber geschrieben ja
soldo aber er kann halt auch nicht
einfach dann so tun als wäre jetzt ganz
frisch aus der ganzen sache raus hatte
niemanden therapeuten gesprochen und
kein geld damit verdient also nein
ich muss sicher unterschreiben
was das netz darüber denkt also die
junge fans ist das alles fake oder ist
das ehrlich von eric das werden wir uns
jetzt einmal anschauen in unserem junge
radar
tag 11 dschungel und twitter läuft
weiter heiß unter dem hashtag ibis für
ich bin ein star kriegt auch dieses mal
eric steht fest sein fett weg nach rx
kriegserklärung folgt die große
entschuldigung dient dem die twitter
user nicht ab hier die top 5 der besten
jetzt so wie erik und schon wieder ein
neues buch von eric stoßfest neun tage
fake wie ich alle mit meiner psycho
packe im kämpfer asche ein bestseller
mit seinem us tut mir so leid gerede
kann eric die twitter gemeinde nicht
überzeugen wenn eric sich nun ganz
plötzlich entschuldigen möchte oder ich
bei rx entschuldigung ich fein gleich
das ist so peinlich für noch mehr
unverständnis sorgt vor allem die
reaktion der mit camper wenn alle nett
mit eric umgehen obwohl er sich maximal
scheiße verhalten hat das ein witz oder
hatte man doch gehofft dass eric aus dem
dschungel muss stattdessen trifft ist
tina ruland an die die für eric
angerufen haben krieg zur anzeige
erich stoßfest ja die user sind immer
sehr kreativ und scheinbar auf deiner
und auch ein bisschen mehr normal und
wer hat denn absolut neues boot zu recht
kann mir sehr gut vorstellen dass da
noch etwas kommt ja wir wollen jetzt
noch mit einer anderen person sprechen
ja wir haben noch einen anderen star
gast heute bei uns in der sendung ich
will nicht zu viel verraten ich kann
ihnen aber sagen wie tänze auf jeden
fall
in
2223 tagen mit dani büchner um die welt
2016 wird ihr düsseldorf zu klein
fernweh sie tauscht düsseldorf und rein
gegen palmen und mittelmeer fliegt
1700 kilometer
und landet auf mallorca doch sie
verschwindet nicht von der bildfläche im
gegenteil ab jetzt kümmert sie auf allen
deutschen mattscheiben von wegen goodbye
deutschland sie können sich urlaub vom
ballermann und zieht 1200 km weiter ins
sommerhaus der stars von sangria
saufenden strohhalm touristen zu den
pöbel promis in portugal erholung
pustekuchen
dani hat einen langen atem und weiß sich
zu verteidigen auch gegen bis sie
geschlagen
rekordverdächtige stippvisite im 18.000
kilometer entfernten australischen
dschungelcamp zwölf von zwölf prüfungen
mehr geht nicht am ende gibt's platz
drei bronze
doch das reicht ihr nicht ihr nächstes
reiseziel köln ossendorf dort warten
noch mehr problemen promis eingesperrt
in einem container in
2223 tagen um die welt und ihr
endgültiges reiseziel der welt buschfunk
hallo dani büchi
und genau da wo ich jetzt dann die
bücher ich freue mich sehr dass wir
dabei sind heute hallo die allererste
frage natürlich auch an sie eric steht
fest beschäftigt alle sie waren im
dschungel sie wissen was es bedeutet da
zu sein unter druck zu stehen auch für
sie war die zeit damals nicht leicht
weil sie kurz nach dem tod ihres mannes
ins camp gezogen sind sie wissen was das
bedeutet unter druck zu stehen hätten
sie so etwas gemacht und vor allem
hätten sie wie hätten sie reagiert wenn
sie dagewesen werden naja man kennt mich
ein zwischen ich glaube ich höre
komplett ausgelastet weil auch wenn
niemand scheiße du bist du bist im team
punkt und ich hätte das nicht mitgemacht
wichtig
sind klare ganz klare aussage wollen wir
mal ein bisschen nach vorne blicken
jeden den ich hier frage der sagt immer
mein favorit ist harald glööckler der
wird das ding nach hause fahren wie ist
ihre meinung dazu wer hat die besten
chancen vielleicht so die top 3
1 für mich top eins ist schon lieb ich
hoffe dass er gewinnen wird ich bin den
typen lega ich habe immer kurz gelang es
lustig ist authentisch er ist so der
macht was jungs von nebenan
harra glück da würde ich den zweiten
satz geben und den dritten so naja
das schwierig / karenz sie auch wenn den
leuten auf den sack geht aber sie ist
unterhaltsam und der wrestler kann ja
schon mal gegen zürich gibt das so
jemanden der für sie so ein bisschen
enttäuschung war in diesem jahr wo sie
vorher gesagt hätten den sehe ich weit
vorne da hätte ich mir irgendwie auch
jetzt im nachhinein aber dann auch mehr
erhofft mehr erwünscht
w nicht so wirklich also von anfang an
war ich teams sie liebt deswegen da ist
noch drin
die ein oder andere personen die
vielleicht schon vorher rausgeflogen ist
wo ich mir dachte okay dass mancher
nimmt man einfach den mund auch zur
scholle man unterschätzt den dschungel
dass kein kindergeburtstag und egal was
du dir von und es klappt meistens nicht
weil es ist eine schwierige
außergewöhnliche situation wo du
wirklich an seine grenzen kommt die
zähne hat er im studio bei philipp auch
gerade schon gelegt was macht er denn so
richtig
ich finde einfach erst wirklich
authentisch und sympathisch er es lustig
nur ist mir ist und das finde ich an so
toll das mag ich und er hat gestern die
entschuldigung angenommen
obwohl ich glaube es ist ihm gar nicht
so leicht gefallen und trotzdem hat er
es gemacht und auch die situation mit
der ist als auch super und das mag ich
habe glück gleis auf net erneut wird er
hat doch einmal 1000 euro die brauche
doch nicht oder konnte jemand anders
geben
also wenn es danach geht sollte verlegt
wirklich jemand anders die krone
bekommen wir müssen noch einmal über
mein leben
gestern abend tatsächlich wir müssen
noch einmal über eine andere sache
sprechen gestern abend haben erzählt
dass sie frisch getrennt sind und
angeblich hat sich
ja sie waren in der kennenlernphase ihr
freund so hell hat sich angeblich per
social media getrennt musste jetzt mal
fragen stimmt das mit der trennung per
social media und vor allem wenn ja
wie geht man denn mit sowas um also ich
würde ja
ich sag mal so was jeder der mich kennt
ich versuche immer öffentliche
schlammschlachten zu vermeiden egal was
jemand anderes über mich sagt oder macht
oder tut oder schreibt auch gerade
aktuell ich habe gestern abend habe ich
zu diesem thema gesagt und ich bin heute
nacht ich habe zwei drei stunden
geschlafen
eigenschaft mit dem gedanken ab heute
ist es keine rede mehr wert ich habe
alles gesagt und man wenn man social
media verfolgt dann sieht man das kann
man sich sein eigenes bild darüber
machen und für mich ist ab heute einfach
keine gehörtes thema ab heute wird der
blick und formen die auch mit meinen
besten freundinnen über sehr gute dafür
sind beste freundinnen ja auch da ich
bedanke mich ganz herzlich für dieses
gespräch
und ja ich bin gespannt auf die prognose
für lieb auf der auf der eins auf platz
1 dann am ende eintritt oder nicht
wir werden sehen und liebe grüße an euch
danke
danke schön
[Musik]
zehn jahre du hast hier gerade gesagt
für liebt ja also für lieb ich habe ihn
ja in dem in tiny house in der
dschungelshow kennengelernt und halt
auch ganz live und ganz ganz nah erlebt
wie er das kriegen da gerockt hat
deswegen können natürlich von herzen wie
gesagt mit dabei war gesehen hat er
gekämpft hat und wie viel scheiße der
jungen gefressen hat also eine kuh augen
aber er hat es diese prüfung auch so
toll gemacht und ich finde er könnte das
jetzt schon gewinnen wer gehört führt
dich als nächstes raus also wer sagt du
musst als nächstes eigentlich gehen wird
nicht mehr verlieren in dieser in diese
in diesem camp zu sein ich muss
tatsächlich sagen anouschka renzi aber
ganz einfach ich bin ja auch ein großer
fan von ehrlichkeit und aber dass sie
sagt sie ist ja auch nur mit die kohle
noch abzustauben und eigentlich für sie
auch haus und eigentlich will sie auch
nicht und eigentlich weiß ich gar nicht
was ihr wilder in dem punkt und dann
soll ich ja okay ist so unterhaltsam
aber dass man die leute drin hier drin
bleiben wollen weil so die richtig bock
haben die beiden gezwungen halt auch so
aus einfach spaß haben wollen und ich
hoffe einfach dass man ein bisschen mehr
von ich habe seinen namen vergessen dass
absolut kein gutes zeichen für ihn
manuell
war nur sieht dass es noch ein bisschen
stattfinden kann wir ansonsten eher ganz
ehrlich erika also naja herrscht bei
eric ja ja ja also für xenia gehört eric
auf jeden fall als nächstes raus und an
nur weil sie nicht im camp bleiben
möchte wir sind gespannt wie es war aber
werde es nicht dass ich wirklich
wahnsinnig attraktiv für auch noch
schlimmer seite also sich verhält wie
ein arschloch das ist aber wird es aber
frauen sind trigger ding zehn jahren
nicht erreicht hat ist wohl das muss ich
jetzt noch einmal fragen was findest du
also attraktiv annehmen ich habe keine
ich sagen also das ist genau der typ auf
den ich mein fallen würde und würde mit
meiner rosa brille das eigentlich erst
nach dem jahr schätzen wenn er schon mit
ihm verlobt war und wer die hälfte
meines geldes hat ja merken ja leider
ich muss sie enttäuschen eric steht dass
es kann jedenfalls aber im glück weiß
ja mal das große liebes outing von
prinzessin zehn jahre von sachsen und
dann ist da prinz eric steht fest und
dann heißt bis er nicht mehr ein ritter
aus dem jahr 1311 sondern dann ist er
prinz von sachsen von gut einem jahr
würden sie ist natürlich als aller
erstes bild erfahren